[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful
financially triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's the number to
jump in it is your show america it's all
about you i'm ken coleman joined by
george campbell and we are here for you
this hour it is a free call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five we wanna help you win
we'll talk about your money obviously
george is here ready to go
coming up how to combat inflation and
protect your four walls we'll get into
that that's gonna be in the shower of
course i'm here today to help you with
your work questions because the best way
to grow your wealth is your income and
so if you want to get a bigger shovel
you get a debt faster i'm here to help
if you want to get out of a toxic work
environment dealing with a tough leader
we'll change your name location because
we know those calls are sensitive so we
are here you ready to go george i'm
ready let's do this all right rodney's
up first in san diego california rodney
how can we help yes thank you for taking
my call so i am considering paying off
my house uh in the next year so maybe
tomorrow who knows but
my wife and i have saved up a
pretty good nest egg i am retired now um
pretty at a young age and my only debt
is my house so
i've heard lots of
things about okay keeping money on hand
so we have enough money on hand to pay
for our house and have money left over
so what is your take of paying a house
free and clear at such a young age how
old are you
i'm 47. whoa
and retired by the way i would like to
point out i am retired that rodney is in
fact young because i'm 47. and uh i
would like to clear that up kelly would
like as well with kelly and i are both
from the same year so kelly it's nice to
hear somebody call themselves young at
our age all right very nice
so rodney how much money are we talking
here what's left on the mortgage and how
much do you have total in cash
uh my mortgage or what's left on my
mortgage is 271k
my wife and i have 370k
in um liquid savings and checking and
then we also have
341k and retirement accounts
wow hold on can i slow clap for rodney
yeah
i feel like it's amazing fantastic so
george what is he waiting on that's what
i'm wondering at all so why were you
socking away all this money i mean
that's an impressive amount to just be
hanging on to in cash
so i was talking on to it for a while
just in case we had an emergency we have
zero debt uh my wife
i had a significant emotional event in
2010 um
and then uh you know came back from that
and then now you sucked it away and it
was very difficult so now i'm retired
from the military so people say hey keep
six months of expenses in your bank
account just in case you get fired but
you know there's no way i can get fired
from being retired well but hold on a
second so let's what's six months six
months of your expenses is what what's
that number
uh my six months of expenses is
six times four twenty four twenty four
days that would go down once you pay off
the mortgage right
yeah so if our three seven zero would be
minus 270 if i paid down my mortgage or
if i paid off my mortgage i'm paying it
off today man
completely debt free and what's your
mortgage payment
my mortgage payment is 18.01 1801 times
12. and you just gave yourself a rent
yeah i know i i i did after property
taxes and insurance i am adding 1500 to
my uh spending cash every month because
right now i have a military pension and
my uh disability coming in so um oh by
the way rodney you still have six months
and more expenses six months and more
yeah exactly so you can invest that you
can start to get into real estate and
purchase real estate with cash i mean
the world is your oyster at baby step
seven where you can live and give like
no one else and that's what i want so
yeah right now we're investing and we've
been investing since 2004. um up and
down and uh it's not doing so well right
now so i was just thinking okay well i
might as well just have liquid cash
coming in every month essentially i
would be
i save about two thousand dollars a
month and if i paid off my house now i
add fifteen hundreds on fifteen hundred
dollars
have we asked what the house is worth
yet what is the house worth rodney oh
good question
my house is worth right now around the
corner someone bought the same model
house for uh 8 15. oh let's go
so
rodney i i mean dude this is
unbelievable good for you
house is worth eight plus george i'm
doing it and rodney can i just say thank
you so much for your service and your
sacrifice
i appreciate your incredible take a long
time to get here
that's incredible
really and yeah right right now my only
band of my existence is fighting with
the other drivers dropping off my kid at
school and picking them up and oh not to
mention my son's college is already paid
for because i passed on benefits to him
oh my goodness rodney you do need to do
something
what are you doing i do need to do
something yes i know what are you going
to do for the next 40 50 years
uh right now i volunteer once a month
and then i take out
friends for coffee once a week to you
know try to encourage them that you know
they do better in life that's what i try
to do that's what i do in my retirement
age when i'm not working out or cleaning
my house this is the final step of ken's
clear path is to give yourself away yeah
i i actually you know what rodney i'm
going to give you a copy of my latest
book it's a bestseller called from
paycheck to purpose
and i think it's going to help you find
work whether you do it volunteer or
whether you do it part-time or you have
a second career i think it's going to
help you with this next stage because
you're a young man and you can truly
give yourself away through work which is
the seventh stage of the seven stages
that i write about the book it's give
yourself away
you're working for like
yeah i'm glad you guys mentioned that
because my wife right now works and she
enjoys her job for me
going to work right now is not for a
monetary compensation it's more
purposely for fulfillment and trying to
give back to the people i feel who can
give back to the community so that's you
know that's what i'm trying to find i've
been retired for about 17 months right
now and i'm saying okay well maybe i'll
find something
so hang on the line i'm going to give
you a copy of the book from paycheck to
purpose and uh what's great about this
george and rodney's case is that he has
he can take all the time he wants to
figure out what that next chapter looks
like because of financial peace he's got
options now yeah and one thing i want
you to do rodney go to
ramseysolutions.com
checkup i want you to take our coverage
checkup because you've worked so hard
offensively to get to where you are now
i want you to focus on defense and make
sure you have enough insurance in place
that you're all of the areas are covered
so that nothing can take away from what
you have built up so so diligently
yeah just an unbelievable story and and
george
this is a great way to start the show
here we have a military family
who their everyday you know millionaires
baby steps millionaires the whole nine
yards they're doing it the right way
they did it you could hear in his voice
it's been a long journey yeah but they
did it george it's doable most people
want the shortcuts and rodney even
retiring at 47 he put in a lot of a lot
of work a lot of years a lot of blood
sweat tears to get to where he is today
and it started a long time ago and so i
want to encourage you you can make that
decision today to start
and it may look different for you you
may not be a millionaire tomorrow but
man 20 years from now you're going to be
thanking your 20 year old self when
you're 40 going man i'm glad i did the
hard work i'm glad i was diligent i'm
glad i was patient i'm glad i was
consistent that's what this plan is all
about yeah just unbelievable story and
uh boy you gotta love it when somebody
calls up and goes should i pay the house
off and you get to say yes today yeah no
one mortgage yeah i'm unbelievable great
great great that needs to be party
rodney paying off the house party
tonight somewhere in san diego
california and as george said thank you
for your service to our country you are
a great american all right don't move
coming up next more of your calls
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year
netsuite gives you the visibility and
control of the things you need to grow
like your financials inventory hr
planning budgeting and more all in one
dashboard go to netsuite.com ramsey
right now to get their free whitepaper
jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right folks welcome back to the
ramsey show thrilled to have you with us
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell and we are here for you
this hour as we talk about your life
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five marissa joins us now
in bend oregon marissa how can we help
hi there um my question is what type of
529 plan is best the state-sponsored one
or one through like um an edward jones
or somewhere like that
that's a great question so uh how old
are the kids
uh nine and twelve so starting a little
late okay hey that's all right the fact
that you're even having this
conversation is amazing most parents
don't and then they just hope and wish
and then the kid ends up with a hundred
grand in student loans so i applaud you
for even
looking into this kind of thing so when
it comes to 529s
there are a lot of options out there
each state has their own and what's
really cool is that you can be a part of
utah's 529 plan no matter where you live
and so what i would be doing is reaching
out to a smartvestor pro in your area
you can jump on ramseysolutions.com
and they can actually walk you through
all of the options out there across the
country and help you choose the right
state for you i would go that route
before jumping uh into one with an
edward jones nothing wrong with those
kinds of companies but i want to make
sure that you're kind of looking without
going with a captive company to start
and so our smart investor pros
they can actually point out the best
state-sponsored plan that's right for
you have you looked into an esa as well
no i haven't okay that one does have an
income limit and there are contribution
limits so depending on your financial
situation on that end
that could be an option for you
okay and the kids are doing 4-h animals
so they're going to have money to
contribute as well so we want them to
start investing that you know quick as
quickly as possible too yeah that's
great and you guys are in uh bandorian
there so are they planning on going to
an in-state school
um they're kind of unsure actually their
dad went to school in texas so that's of
course where they're where they're
leaning isn't that funny how that works
you know it's funny it's true is this
sports related as well like is a big
texas sports house or not at all not not
necessarily my husband's an ag and um
you know and that's what they're they're
into i went to an oregon school but but
it's not it's not as cool as the texas
schools
well i just don't want you making a
decision based on where dad went and
then the kid ended up ends up paying
twice as much to go to school
unfortunately oregon schools are
expensive regardless of in state or out
of state everything's expensive in
oregon i'm told yes
yes oregon is expensive so no definitely
going to take advantage of community
college and you know that kind of stuff
as well good so well they're young they
don't you know a nine-year-old doesn't
have to have their life figured out yet
so that's the good news very early let's
not uh and just a caution to parents you
know let's
let kids discover more you suggest less
oh discover more suggest less
pay attention parents observe more but
if parents shut up a little bit
and stop suggesting everything based on
what makes you feel good or what you did
and you actually observed your kids and
i'm not saying that marissa's doing this
i'm saying i'm kind of challenging
parents just real quick throw a little
nugget out there
start observing your kids a lot more and
pay attention to clues even at 9 10 and
11 and that's going to inform a lot of
things when they're 16 17 and 18 as well
all right the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
vandana joins us in washington dc
vandana how can we help
hi yes on friday we closed on a house
and
because of this market we were very fast
to just buy it
because we
had to
and i just regret it even when we had
like the three days hoa clause i wanted
out but my husband really wanted to just
go ahead and get it
until i just kind of did it so we
wouldn't fight and ever since then i've
regretted it and we closed on friday and
have cried every single day since then i
feel like we made a mistake
i'm sorry what hat tell me what is the
tell george and i the specific things
you're regretting right now
well
i mean we had to move so my daughter
could go to school because
we live across the street it's like the
stupidest district
and we wanted to do it because she could
be in the better school
she could be with her friends and
everything
and
she has some special needs and this
school has
this for the school that for her to be
able to go to for middle school has more
of the programming that she needs so we
did it for that no i understand
but listen that's a good thing what are
you specifically regretting i just feel
like it's a little bit
i don't know i just feel like we made a
big mistake we're gonna have to spend so
much money fixing this house and it's
gonna be more of a mortgage
and you know i found out my husband took
out a heloc to pay for it and
i found out all these things financially
as we were doing it i wonder if i just
did it so we could i found out my
husband owned i had a 50 000 personal
loan that i didn't know about i thought
we had paid off all our debts besides
our student loans oh i'm so sorry
bandana it sounds like there's there's
some financial infidelity on top of the
weight of an impulsive home purchase
here uh and so then
so he did the heloc which
i learned about
as he was doing it and now that i've
learned more about he lost and listening
to you i'm a little bit scared because
that's what we used to pay for this
house
and
you know
we paid off
we paid off the person alone from the
heloc 2 so we could close on this house
and yeah now we can definitely it's not
that we can't afford this house now
because all the
debt is gone but i just i don't know
okay okay so the house sounds like we
robbed peter to pay paul here we just
got to move the debt around
bandana george's gonna walk you through
this but here's what i want okay you
need to just
focus right now on less emotion and
start plugging in some numbers for
george all right so i'm gonna get us
started okay what's your household
income and then what is the mortgage
cost of you give us those two numbers
so our
household income is 250 000
before
taxes
before taxes
700 to 900 a month what's the mortgage
including the heloc so all that together
what is that
i don't know including the he rock how
about just the mortgage okay just the
mortgage
just the mortgage is about including
like hoa in taxes is about 4
500. okay
so if i'm doing the math here you're
looking at
34
of your take-home pay
yeah is going into so now that's that's
higher than what i'd like it to be but
it's not killing you
like you said you guys can afford it
yeah i think a lot of the emotion is
coming from the fact that you're
learning a lot of things you didn't know
because your husband lied to you
yeah i think so and yes you did
impulsively get into this house but
that's not the bigger issue here the
bigger issue is that you and your spouse
need to get on the same page and go
we're married there are no lies in this
relationship
and so i think that's going to be your
a1 is not fixing the house problem it's
fixing the relationship problem and that
might look like counseling that might
look like going through financial peace
university together on top of that
but we got to get to the root of why he
hid these things from you
i think he was just the same
because before he had credit card debt
and i sold my condo and literally i gave
him every single dollar out of my condo
i was a teacher i quit working
after
during the pandemic so i could
homeschool my child and i haven't wanted
to go back because for the few months i
did
i did teach
i was so stressed out and i went back
for a little bit this year and my
anxiety went up i wasn't sleeping
nothing and was like i just had to put
he put on anxiety medicine just taking
these days is just so difficult and i
just couldn't deal with
everything and then
you know
i or i thought we were out of debt i
thought we were completely out of debt
because when i found out about the
credit cards i i had a condo that i had
oh my goodness i'm so sorry vandana we
are so so very sorry but as george said
i want you to walk away from this to say
hey you and your hubs just see you on
the same page if you had some shame
take the shame away and just say hey can
we get on the same page i'm feeling a
tremendous amount of anxiety and fear
over this you guys know how to pay debt
off start attacking it just like you
were starting all over again
you guys can get there house isn't going
to fall in on itself it's going to be
okay but you guys have got to get on the
same page relationally
so that you can get on the same page
financially coming up george is going to
take on
inflation in your four walls this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
all right folks the ramsay show
continues from our
nashville-based world hq thrilled to
have you with us i'm ken coleman
and george campbell my colleague is with
me today and george of every day in the
news
inflation inflation inflation it's like
that you know those old car commercials
price down you know
yeah it's like inflation is everywhere
and it is at all time highs
uh and yet george what's interesting
about this is that we're also in a
season of life in america where incomes
are up but because inflation is so high
in some cases it's a net net meaning
you're not getting ahead uh you've got
some you've got some current news and
data on this yeah so what's going on
we're going to do a series helping you
guys out with what we call your four
walls so this is food utilities housing
and transportation those are the big
ones that people are worried about right
now so we're gonna start with food today
give you guys some quick tips now these
aren't you know life-changing hacks
they're gonna save you hundreds of
dollars but it can help to avoid you
feeling that pinch every time you go to
the grocery store all right so let's
jump in here uh we did a state of
personal finance study and we found that
groceries have jumped about eight
percent which tracks with inflation here
and the average cost of monthly
groceries for one person went from 223
to 410 and for a family of four it
shoots up to 863 dollars now a lot of
you were going oh my gosh that's it or
oh my gosh that much you know what the
data doesn't cover the coleman household
where i have two teenage boys that's
like three extra people that's true the
amount of groceries i got those boys can
eat i've seen them one pack of bacon gum
gum in one morning well that brings me
to my first tip here kevin we gotta shop
at the cheapest grocery store there it
is a lot of people they have their
grocery store and you can't you can't
get ken coleman away from publix you
know everyone's got their groceries i'm
a kroger guy wow yeah i wouldn't take it
for a kroger guy really but shopping's a
pleasure at publix i know you're a man
of leisure and pleasure that's a tag
line i'm all about convenience and
there's one in the neighborhood oh that
makes sense that makes sense well aldi
is one of the best grocery stores this
is not sponsored but they just happen to
have great prices my parents shop
exclusively at aldi they carry on about
how they save money they're retired they
get it it's simple it's no frills you
got to pay for a bag you got to put a
quarter in the cart i mean they they're
they're making sure that they're able to
give you those low prices in different
ways so aldi i love trader joe's for
their prices uh walmart can be great
costco can be braided if you do it right
now costco can be a danger zone when you
get four things and it cost you nine
thousand dollars because you tried the
rice peel off sample and just had to
have a four pound bag well who doesn't
need a six pack of polish cabasa
you know what i mean you can't just buy
one pack i'm here for that yeah so
choosing a cheaper grocery store for
right now you don't have to go to whole
foods we can go to aldi and get the same
thing uh just might not be the name
brand you know go generic go with the
store brand you'll be okay big generic
brand guy number two i want you to look
for foods that give you more bang for
your buck so we talk a lot about beans
and rice here never has it been more
true beans and rice rice and beans it's
one of the cheapest staple foods and
it's filling yeah let me tell you
something bow tie pasta i'm giving real
life coleman house hacks as you go along
bow tie pasty you could buy six boxes
for a dollar forty six unbelievable get
those carbs rice pastas those are cheap
get some sauce yeah pasta's cheap and uh
buying your meat in bulk as meat is
getting expensive here
so uh there's one right there number two
and number three actually cut out the
wants and only buy the items you need
no frivolous chocolate chip cookies are
getting thrown in the cart ken oh it's
tough what is the actual food that is
going to sustain our family i really
like ice cream and i can make a case
that it sustains my mental health well
we're going store brand and we're going
to get the full gallon to save yeah on
coffee well i'm all about the gallon of
ice cream there you go yeah there's your
hat ken so make sure that you're you
know you're talking with your spouse if
you've got one about the grocery budget
and looking for ways that we can cut
things out and making sure nothing
frivolous gets added to that list
now lastly ken this is one that you
probably don't do but cashback apps yeah
i don't even know what that means i'm a
fan so there's apps like they're called
ibotta fetch rewards there's one called
checkout 51 receipt hog and what you do
receipt hog yes if i was gonna be into
one that would be the one that i was
that i would just based on the name just
i could tell my friends on the phone
yeah i got this new app or a seat hog
that's fun to say
i don't know who your friends are but i
hope they enjoy it well you actually do
so here's they're simple you uh upload
your receipt and you'll get cash back
for certain items you buy really tell
you you know what about my ice cream i
get cash back on my uncertain brands
now here's the catch i don't want you to
buy the name brand ice cream that's two
dollars more to save a dollar when you
could have got the generic brand so
still shop wisely you're stepping on my
test only shop what's in your budget uh
but it could it could help you get some
money back if you spend 80 bucks you
might get five ten bucks back that helps
every little bit goes a long way so
remember uh actual paper coupons
remember these can i flip these on
sundays with my dad growing up oh yeah
big fan of the paper coupon a lot of
them have gone digital now yeah but all
of these take an extra step it takes a
little bit more uh research it takes a
little bit more patience and diligence
to make sure that before you impulsively
walk through the grocery store and then
get mad that prices are high you go in
with a list you go in with a budget you
go in with a plan and you go in willing
to make some sacrifices in order to save
some money is there a rule of thumb
george on how much a person could save
let's say you've got a
uh let's say you're gonna go spend 200
bucks as your budget or 300 bucks at the
grocery store can you how much of that
could you save
oh
i'm gonna go if you can shave paper or
digital coupons i think if you can shave
off five or ten percent of each purchase
i'm calling that a win so i've seen
these stories like where people get
their entire thing for free that's not
that's not real well you can do that but
you're not to be able to survive off of
that because you can't drink thai
detergent
well you know it's just not good for you
the kids are doing it the kids are doing
all kinds of stupid so you know you know
what i mean though you're not gonna you
can't do that with so ten percent five
to ten percent is a realistic and so all
of a sudden i mean which is the amount
of inflation we're seeing yeah so it
combats that if you can save eight
percent and inflation's eight percent
it's net zero yeah so there's some quick
tips for you all i know it's there's no
easy hack i wish i could give you some
amazing news but it really just takes
some diligence some sacrifice and some
research in order to get through these
strange times when we're seeing
groceries up eight percent but also
let's not get crazy it's eight percent
so if it was you know a dollar now it's
a dollar eight
we're not talking three four five
dollars more for that same thing and
this goes with eating out too see now
okay now george this is why you are a
ramsey personality a thought leader and
you you're winning this space because
you just said math well because here's
the deal
you would you make a very good point on
the eight percent and you put it in real
dollars and cents all right
people freak out because that's all we
get fed or negative headlines right the
sky is not falling no
you know like because i i i hear the
stories too
and i'm like well i mean and again i
really i'm not making a joke i have two
athlete boys in my house that are 16 and
13. my 16 year old is a man child
i mean i eat a side of he's twice my
size and i'm a grown man yeah i need to
get longhorns in the backyard that's the
kind of rate of which we are going
through protein i'm serious so we've
seen our bill jump
but at the same time it's not like the
end of the world a little bit of
discipline a little bit of budgeting and
you can you can make your way through
this yeah well our plan works in good
times and bad and so times of inflation
you go all right we have margin on our
budget because that's how we live our
lives we live on less than we make we
have an emergency fund we don't have
debt and therefore all that money can go
towards helping us survive inflation and
so that's what i want to remind people
is follow these steps do this plan
because it works and you know i was just
talking to my neighbor yesterday and we
were complaining about gas prices oh of
course i just got an electric car and so
therefore i don't know
here's what she said and she said you
know what at the end of the day i'm
grateful because i can actually afford
it it's not fun but i can afford it and
that level of contentment that's
something that we need to have as a
society and go hey listen i'm not going
to be bankrupted by grocery prices yeah
and so there's a lot of people out there
who are really really hurting and i have
a lot of empathy for those people but
for most americans this is just a man
that stinks
gas is a hundred bucks to fill up
instead of 50. yeah same deal we get
back to the budget
that we talk about when you know where
your money's going a budget is a plan
that tells your money where to go then
you can weather this stuff coming up the
rest of this week we're going to take on
the rest of the four walls this kind of
great content george you'll take on
utilities then housing then
transportation with food make up the
four walls that's what we call it ramsey
solution those basic fundamental needs
and we're going to help you fight the
inflation uh so that's coming up george
before we uh get uh moving on here in
the program i need to know people want
to know is it coupon or coupon
i'm a big fan of coupon you're a coupon
not a coupon guy okay
i'm a coupon oh no i'm cue he's coo
all right discuss it amongst yourselves
however you are watching or listening to
the show i think it's cute i'll send you
hate mail just for that what's saying
all right we'll uh maybe we'll reveal
coming up next we'll take a poll inside
the control room and we'll see what the
ramsey solutions ramsay show team has
decided is it coupon or is it coupon i
think i'm on the right side of history
here we'll see coming up next more of
your calls don't move
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
all right america welcome back to the
ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague george campbell and uh i told
you folks if you're with us last segment
uh we were talking about the value of
coupons and i asked george i said is it
q
or ku
he said it's ku as in coupon versus
coupon i said we would reveal the
results so we uh we we pulled the
control room and george you said you
felt that you were on the right side of
history i shall give you the results are
you prepared to handle i hope so okay
according to the control room okay uh
that includes us
so they would put us into the tally it
was 5q
tuku
james me and james james and bobby okay
so it was okay and so then we went out
to the lobby where we have a fantastic
audience by the way uh watching live in
the lobby of ramsey solutions and we
went out to take pictures and i just
took a quick informal poll i said is it
cue or coup and the lobby was resounding
that it was cue so george you know what
the other side of history they're all
from the midwest ken it's not fair oh
george it's a different breed there's
careful see i got some head nods out
there right i got my coupon uh george
there you go hacking off the audience
all right so there it is folks this is
the kind of stuff you come here for uh
hey we've got an exciting announcement
george hit me uh we've been talking
about on the show about the building
wealth live event making a stop in
orlando on may 19th you and i will both
be there can't wait it's gonna be fun
with dave ramsey rachel cruz john
deloney uh but before we get there we're
making another stop drumroll please
george
thank you that's very good very good uh
we're going to vegas baby yeah hey
viva too much no we're off the air now
okay viva las vegas we're coming to you
thursday
may 5th thursday may 5th building wealth
is a hot topic right now everybody's got
an opinion on how to do it whether it's
crypto single stocks or zero down real
estate
and then you've got inflation
so we're going to walk you through
what's going on today teach you how to
build real wealth the financial
principles that we teach are the only
principles that work in prosperous times
and in hard times so we want you to
become baby steps millionaires we want
you to join us um at this event oh it's
going to be good building wealth live
join dave ramsey rachel cruz george
campbell dr john deloney and myself
uh vegas
is where we're gonna be may the fifth in
orlando on may the 19th tickets start at
just 25
or you can get a four pack for only 60
bucks
this is a great deal so don't wait
tickets are selling fast go right now
ramsay solutions dot com
slash events that's ramsey solutions dot
com slash events ken can i just say the
irony of us going to las vegas to teach
you how to get rich slow yeah i know
it's rich i know and i might break out
the polyester leisure suit for that
event i'm not sure we'll just kind of
hung on to it for a time such as this
yeah you never know when you're gonna
need that so i might break that out all
right let's get to the phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
salt lake city utah is where we join jay
jay how can we help
hey good afternoon ken george thanks for
taking the call
i'm kind of curious how to navigate
holding a full-time job
but starting something on the side that
you would eventually want to
take full time basically work for
yourself i'm kind of in a position now
where i trust
the possibility of working for myself
even though there are obviously
negatives and positives um but just kind
of making that transition while working
full-time
um
it's
something that i
think of these different scenarios you
know every day and they could choose
from one day to the next um okay so real
estate licensed insurance licenses and i
want to
take that full time eventually and work
for myself which one
are you trying to decide which is the
best path
right yes
real estate obviously i think is
kind of a you know
transaction you could do a lot better on
but insurance seems to be more stable
i'm just
trying to figure out how i can navigate
that and see what's going to work all
right so let's just i don't know who
else to go to sure okay so i'm glad you
called
is your heart leaning towards one of
those two
a little bit more in other words do you
get a little bit more excited and i
don't mean of the possibilities because
you were leaning right
the way you described real estate versus
insurance was possibility based and i
appreciate that that's your head i want
to take your head out of this question
for a moment
and i want to hear what your heart says
is there one insurance or real estate
that you get more excited about
emotionally as it relates to the work
itself
i would say without a doubt real estate
okay so great all right so that would be
the one that i would choose as the
leader here's what i want you to do
if you haven't already done it i want
you to use the proximity principle i'm
going to give you a copy of that number
one best-selling book when we uh hang up
with you so that you can really dive
deep on this but the proximity principle
is is is a very simple thought it says
this in order to do what i want to do in
this case it's real estate sales
i got to get around people that are
doing that and in places where it is
happening here's what i want you to do i
want you to hang out with a couple
successful real estate professionals in
your area
whether you know one maybe it's one you
use to buy a house or sell a house
or a friend of a friend or friend of a
family member and i just want you to
pick their brain take them to coffee and
go hey
what do you love most about what you do
what do you like the least what's a
great day look like how did you get
successful what what would you say to
somebody who wants to be as successful
as you it's basically like doing a
college term paper with them here's what
you're doing there i want you to do that
two or three times and in doing so we
want to give now some great logic we're
going to engage the brain again to match
up with the heart you go okay i
absolutely know that i know that i know
that i would not only enjoy this but
that i would be good at it that's what i
would call clarify and verify okay
that's the first part of your question
the second part of your question is
how do i go about moving from day job
to dream job you said side hustle how do
we work in a full-time job and then grow
something on the side now with real
estate i got to tell you it's a little
bit different my normal answer
jay and george normally my answer is
this all right look it's very simple we
do the side hustle
we grow it to the point where we're
actually making money so that's first
stage right we grow we start small we
grow slow
and we take every nickel we make from
the side hustle jay and we put it in the
bank we don't spend it we just put it
out there and we want to get to a point
this is my rule of thumb
six to 12 months of your current salary
this is not your emergency fund folks if
you're ramsey folks this is an addition
to
so you may have to walk the baby steps
out before you do this but the idea here
is george is that we've got a side
hustle that can become a full-time job
when it pays me
what i make now or close to it with a
great upside that makes sense now now
jake here's the reality i've talked to a
lot of big time real estate pros about
this particular issue
because i wanted to know can you win big
as a part-time real estate agent and
their answer was no at some point you're
going to have to go all in
so what that's going to look like for
you is you're going to have to make sure
your financial house is in order no debt
do you have any debt at all
uh i have no debt i have my mortgage
and i have about three months
in my emergency fund fantastic so you
keep walking the baby steps out so for
you
we are going to we're going to get
licensed and we're going to try to try
to list try to sell we're going to try
to get you know about six months three
to six months of your income in the bank
and then i'd say go all in
because you're in a financial place to
be able to do it you've got an emergency
fund build your pipeline but i think
part-time real estate that's showing
houses on nights and weekends really
growing your personal relationship
uh to a real network of hey uh people
are recommending me for listing or for
buying
and once you get about six months of
your current salary in the bank
jay i'd say go all in george any
financial tips
i'll tell you my dad got into real
estate later in life for fun as a hobby
not trying to take it full time and he
enjoys it but i'll tell you you really
can't win
without doing it full-time he does it
because he wants to help local folks at
his church who are moving here help them
find a place but i think jake can do
this it's just going to be a lot harder
than you think because there's so many
real estate agents out there and there's
not a lot of inventory right now so it
may be best to wait another six months
to a year and get this thing off the
ground before we move in that direction
so the key is you can get started in
real estate part time you really can and
you can stack up enough money to where
you can make the
change notice i didn't say make the jump
make the lead we're going to step off of
the like a step right
yeah i'm not that athletic so i like
that move george it's a good move for
you that's a good move for you
personally and professionally george to
maintain that personal brand hey i want
to thank our team in the control room i
want to thank my colleague george
campbell fun hour thank you sir and also
we want to thank you america this is
your show
this is the ramsey
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell the phone number for you
to jump in is triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five it's toll free let's
go
george and i are here for you we're
going to be real nice to you i promise
and we're going to help you out come up
with some clear steps forward whether
you've got a work issue where you want
to make more money or you're in a toxic
environment with a boss or maybe a
teammate uh or you're just in a
financial mess
we're gonna help you out today and we'd
love to talk to you let's go to los
angeles california the city of angels
teresa is on the line theresa how can we
help
ken how are you i'm living the dream
teresa what are you doing
so i
i used your principles and i went from
having no job to having a job serving
and in the four months that i did my
work environment was so toxic
i put in my notice so my general manager
finds out and says don't go
let's put you somewhere else let's find
a place for you you're a great worker
don't go okay so he puts me in the
office of the restaurant instead i'm on
the back end of things so
it's i'm really happy and excited and my
first day was a few weeks ago and i work
with my direct supervisor and she's very
unhappy with me
she's upset and said i was a red flag
because i quit and i couldn't hack it
and
what do i need to do
to
and so and in this time frame it's been
a few weeks now
i'm not really doing much she already
won't mentor me and won't to train me
to help really an assist her and i know
i could do it
but she doesn't
like me again and said i was a red flag
and i want to know how
i can
get her not to i guess like me but i
guess trust me or
okay i don't know all right so so here's
what i need to know you were placed in
this position by somebody that i'm if
i'm understanding the situation properly
the outranks her correct
yes yes who is that person is that the
general manager the overall like explain
to me that relationship
he's the general manager and she's like
one or two down from him all right and
so he put you there
because he didn't want you to leave the
company he really values you correct
correct does he know about how you're
being treated
no i don't want to say i almost talked
to him but i i don't want to do that
again because i feel like i need to like
earn my street cred with her not true
she's not
yeah let me tell you why
she's not giving you the opportunity to
earn anything from day one it sounds
like to me you can tell me if i'm wrong
but it sounds like to me from day one
she looked at you as somebody she had to
deal with and that's why she was calling
you the red flag because you quit your
other position you can't hack it she
just doesn't like you for a variety of
reasons
but it's all on her side if she's
treating you that like that way from day
one it's not like you did anything wrong
am i right or am i wrong
no you're right there's always something
like we get along but i always thought
there was a wallop with me i don't know
i mean she's a lot younger than me too
so i don't know yeah yes is she newer
no she's been there eight years does she
see you as a threat
maybe
because i did say like look i don't want
your job i just want to help i want to
do this and when i did say that it got
better well you know what's interesting
you said you i'm a little confused i
need you to clarify this you said you
get along with her
but it didn't sound like
well that's not what i heard in the
first two minutes
i get along with anyone if someone gets
along with me it means they like me and
i like them yeah but in this case teresa
gets along with anybody so meaning you
managed to make it
livable yes
yeah yeah it's like you all don't know
terrible
yeah yeah i guess yeah it's like awkward
silences i guess which i hate but yeah
okay so here's the deal you called me
and you said ken george what do i do
all right okay and i'm gonna tell you
you either be a big girl
and go talk to this general manager who
values you and puts you in this
situation to win and you go here's
what's going on i'm just letting you
know i'm not trying to gripe
you put me here you talked me into
staying she's not even using me and it
was from day one there's something there
and i need you to help me navigate it
or this just isn't a fit
you have nothing to lose you were
already on your way out the door once
what are you worried about
you either do that or you just go ahead
and say you know what this isn't the
place for me
because absent of leadership
this gal is not going to change that's
what i know
okay
you agree or disagree okay what's your
gut no i well
she is leaving for a promotion in like a
few in seven months so that's why i
thought like if i just stick it out and
maybe towards the end she would
see that i stayed well you didn't tell
me that
so here's the deal no no i'm glad i'm
not having fun with you here's the deal
can you stick it out can you put up with
this relationship let's call it what it
is it's a work relationship can you put
up with it the way it is right now and
you basically sitting around twiddling
your thumbs not because of you but
because of her can you put up with that
for seven
more
months
yes
all right then what do you want to do
i want to prove myself and i want to
move up i want to move up in the company
i'm excited and so proud of myself that
i went from just in four months so i'm
like this momentum i have i'm like i
want to show that i can do it that i
could be
a great assistant and help and i
appreciate that
but you are telling me that she's not
allowing you to assist or help that's
what you told me
yes here i was hoping you'd say like do
this and then this will awesome but well
we don't do that we don't just tell you
in a situation i know george can tell
you what to do with the baby steps and
money but in a situation like this
i could tell you what i would do and i
already told you that i would sit down
with the gm and go this is okay
unsustainable
okay that's what i would do i would talk
with the gm
um and say well you know what i take
that back george knows it's about me
first thing i do i sit down with this
girl and go what's going on have an
honest conversation have an honest
conversation that doesn't put her on the
defensive
it just says look here's what i'm
feeling do you feel comfortable to have
that conversation with her and say hey
listen i enjoy working with you we're a
team i want us to both win and i feel
like there's like this weird tension am
i wrong and just see what she says yeah
okay yes i do i feel comfortable
absolutely start with her if she can't
have that conversation then you go all
right well hey i'm going up let's let's
go meet with our general manager i just
want to sort this out so we can be
productive so that we can get the job
done and if you don't want to do those
two things
you can stick it out i don't think it's
going to be great for your mental and
emotional wellness to be completely
honest with you but i also think you
could do it i think you can bite the
stick for seven months she clears out um
i don't know if that's going to open up
the opportunity for you to step into her
role or not but again
you do what your heart's telling you to
do here and you know i admire your
willingness to stick it out for seven
months i don't know that i'd do that but
if i felt like that was the best
opportunity you can guarantee i would do
that george yeah i'd suffer i'll suffer
for seven months for a great opportunity
absolutely you've suffered with me just
co-hosting the show i didn't want to say
that but uh now that it's out in the
open folks there's a reason why
george and i suffer each other no george
is the best and absolutely i appreciate
that yeah hey thank you for the call
teresa um it's your call your decision
but you gotta live with the decision
that you make
all right coming up next
more decisions more calls more
breakthrough
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
the ramsay show continues thrilled to
have you with us i'm ken coleman and i'm
joined here in studio by my colleague
george campbell spelled with a k by the
way
okay for that ken no one gets it yeah
you know it occurs to me that i ought to
at least tell some folks every once in a
while it's with the k
cam because they're searching you with a
c so millions of people a day on the
google's looking at google george
campbell with a c and they're getting it
wrong they can't find you thank you for
that i like that i also like the fact
that you said the google because i say
that to my three teenage kids and it
irritates them to no end they must roll
their eyes at full 360. when you do that
that i say the talk instead of tick-tock
that one bothers me personally i say the
gram but john doloni says the internet's
which is the most egregious of them all
is it yeah yeah i remember for a while
there was a thing called the interweb
which was kind of like a internet world
wide web the interweb they were
different things no just that stupid
term that's the mashup anyway we digress
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five detroit michigan the motor
city is where eric joins us next eric
how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call today
i have a question about refinancing a
student loan um i just recently in the
last week refinanced a student loan from
my undergraduate my graduate school for
146 000
and i got a rate of 2.1 percent locked
in for a 10-year term by plan on paying
a lot faster
um when i first started my undergraduate
i was 17 years old and my parents had to
take out a parent plus loan
and i've been paying on that and it was
always understood that i would pay for
that
um and the
current amount on that loan is eighteen
thousand dollars and the apr is seven
percent
and right now it's zero percent because
of the pause but
um
the seven percent on the 18 000
um is in my mom's name and my mom
doesn't have great credit i've looked at
trying to refinance it for her before
but she was never approved for refinance
with her credit and so
on the website that i had used to
refinance my student loan there was a
way to
bring over that loan if i was going to
refinance it from the parent plus and i
just wondered what you guys thoughts
were on me doing that
is this a federal loan or private loan
the parent plus
it's a federal loan i believe because
it's at zero percent but it is through a
private vendor i just know that
currently it's a zero percent okay
because if it's a government loan they
don't allow you to simply transfer it uh
you can do that through a private lender
if you would qualify for that what i
would do the only way i want you
refinancing obviously this is a crazy
high interest rate have you tried going
through our friends at splash financial
to see what their rate would be in their
terms
no no i went through laurel road for my
original refinance just because they had
the best rates um
but i've not checked any yeah give one
give splash financial a shot here's the
parameters though no matter who you go
with it should be completely free to
refinance there should be no fees
you should only go with a fixed interest
rate
and i want you to have a shorter loan
repayment because a lot of times they'll
extend the payment and make you feel
like you won and then lastly make sure
it's a lower interest rate and so if you
can do all those things then i call that
a win but at the end of the day i want
you to pay this thing off as fast as
possible and spend less time playing the
interest rate game trying to get them
lower i do think it'll help because
seven percent on 18 000 that'll grow
pretty fast so check out our friends at
splash financial and see if they can get
you the right terms the right rate and
if so i would do that and move it into
your name but your parents took this out
that was the decision they made and so
they're on the hook and so parents
remember that's a scary situation to be
in do not take out a parent plus loan
the terms are terrible the interest
rates are crazy high and you put both
you and your kids in a real financial
predicament yeah and yeah
there's so many other great options
you don't have to feel this pressure
parents to make a really bad
financial decision for your kid's future
it's just it it breaks my heart to see
so many people
burdened down
with crazy debt that's impacting their
entire life in a negative way all from a
good intention yeah and parents then can
accomplish their own financial goals
because they have a parent plus loan
hanging around there yeah just for a
juicer who didn't even finish college
yeah that's a scary spot to be in that
is all right michelle's up next in san
antonio texas michelle how can we help
hi thank you so much for taking this
call i appreciate it sure
we uh
my husband and i have recently um
actually my husband's business he's sold
a business um but he's been investing in
and working in for probably the last 20
30 years
he got three million dollars and um
we
want to know um what the best um how to
best invest this money we we do have
debt um we have a house and we have cars
um
that probably total tall about
i would say six hundred thousand dollars
in debt
so we do plan on paying that off first
um
our house is worth probably a million
right now
we owe like 485 on it but we're probably
going to stay in it for a while um
so our first thought is of course real
estate um buying a property near the
beach somewhere in texas and you know
putting in a rental pool and and taking
some rental um income from that but
other than that we really don't have a
an idea of what to do
well this is a good problem to have
congratulations
on the sale of the business so exciting
so how old are you two
we are 51. okay well very young by the
way very young that's great have you
guys thought about it
you're both still working or what's
what's going on now that you sold the
business well
my husband is um not going to be able to
work in that business for a year and a
half it's going to non-compete so that's
fine um i am a social worker i make
about 65 000 a year which is not a whole
lot but um pretty good for a social
worker
yeah he um he wants to do maybe
buy
properties fix them up and sell them
he's always
he's always built our homes that we've
made money off of in the past you know
several years and so he's very handy he
can do anything
you know as far as remodeling and things
like that so he's thought about doing
that for a couple years before he can go
back into
well he does want to get back into his
original business
he does in one way shape or form yes
that's great well i'm just i'm trying to
figure out what financially is the best
move for you guys obviously real estate
is a fantastic investment and he's got
the know-how to do that so i would make
that part of your portfolio obviously at
your age you can do some catch-up
contributions and go hog wild in your
retirement investing if you've got those
options available and then beyond that
if you don't have any tax advantage
retirement accounts aside from real
estate you could just put it in
a taxi a taxable brokerage account and
have some of that money grow for you as
well and dave does that he parks in
index funds and once the money grows and
he wants to buy a piece of property he
just takes the money out
and uh pays long-term capital gains on
that and buy some real estate and that
can grow at market rate you know
obviously right now the market's not
great but you know 10 12 percent have
that money grow for you instead of
sitting cash an account would be your
best bet yeah and i michelle has your
husband done any kind of restoration
work before other than piddling around
the house
he's built the last three of our homes
this is an impressive man whoa let me
step back a little bit i thought you
know i said
yeah
okay working full-time yeah yeah that's
impressive ken and i can barely build an
ikea bookshelf together
i can't build anything i can put the gas
in the car i'm limited beyond that a
little bit of air in the tires as well
but here's here's what i was going to
say
george's right gave you sound advice
there i i was just going to say that you
know now he's retired and i would just
be very careful with you know too much
of the restoration investing you know
what i mean because while he's obviously
built a home three homes he knows what
he's doing i'd ease into that a little
bit and i'd really go with george's
other strategies first kind of ease our
way into that because um you know that
restoration business might be a good one
just to get into if he just does
part-time where he's doing kitchens here
bathrooms there he's getting excited you
know he's kind of he's got a little time
to fish or play golf or whatever else
so that was the only caution i had but
clearly he knows what he's doing uh with
the hammer and the nails and all that
george yeah have you ever hammered a
nail george for real i've done it i've
hung a picture or two in my day
that's about it ken i love it you want
to hang a picture i like to support
local handymen in my area in handy women
to do that kind of work well make sure
it's a better life and a better marriage
me and my wife literally ate a pint of
ice cream watching a handyman install a
floating shelf and i went this is worth
50 bucks an hour
totally worth it oh i've got to know
really quick were the feet up or were
they just seated
oh we were full throttle man full
entertainment just watching them you are
pathetic but i love you uh pathetic but
you know my wife said the same thing the
other day exactly perfect all right he's
pathetic but he's smart and he can help
you don't move more of your calls coming
up next this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back folks the ramsay show
continues i'm ken coleman joined by
george campbell we're here taking your
calls aaa 825-5225
you got uh some relationship money or
work issues
that's a big broad invitation come on
we're here to help you remember we'll
change your name location if that helps
if it's a sensitive topic we want to get
you
a practical path forward for some
breakthrough in your life let's get back
to the phones portland maine is where
bryce joins us bryce how can we help
hey ken and ken and george i appreciate
you guys taking my call you bet what's
up
so uh i bought a new car in july of 2021
i'm 18 still living at home with my
parents
and i have around 20 000 left on that
auto loan
my question is i also do some reselling
on the side with uh sneakers so i have
around eighteen thousand dollars
uh worth of collectible nike and jordan
shoes hold on hold on whoa whoa slow
down i want to roll past that you got a
real shoe guy on the line with you with
me and the air jordans i mean are these
vintage are these like newer what
explain this to me
so i i don't have many vintage ones i
have more of the like newer
collaborations yeah um
so i my the question was do i sell them
now
and continue or pay it off in full
um or do i let them build in value
um and continue to make the regular
payments so so are you sell are you
collecting these or are you reselling
so i do a bit of both so basically i'll
try to get two or three pairs if i can
sell one um pay off
the pair that i currently have
um so i can kind of keep one and sell
one and make my money so i basically pay
off the one that i'm holding on to are
you buying these shoes with cash
uh no i use a
credit card oh he whispered it
okay bryce i like this kid i think
you're a real bright guy whispered it
you have an entrepreneurial spirit
clearly you're really good at this
but this thing is going to bite you in
the butt
if you're not careful yeah in fact i got
a question on that george bryce of the
sneakers that you say are 18 000.
are you carrying any debt on that 18 000
worth of sneakers
so right now you have 18 000
in value or liquid value of shoes tennis
shoes
correct and you owe 20 on the car
yes what kind of car is it uh it's it's
a honda civic
okay
honda civic guys this is in your lane
here all right bryce
here's here's two options one you sell
your entire shoe collection that hurts
right
yeah would you even be willing to do
that you called us asking
but are you willing
well i i would if if if i got you know
if i heard the right um
i i need some some opinions that's what
i'm talking let me ask you an honest
question why all of a sudden do you care
about paying off debt
um
i'm just set up
i don't really like to carry
debt you know i i always pay my credit
cards off early when i can
i never make the minimum payment i
always pay them off in full i just don't
like debt so would you agree that
becoming debt free is the best thing you
can do for bryce right now at 18 years
old
yeah okay now george we're going to pop
corn in and out here i got to know how
much is the how much is the car worth
the civic
um
it's
newer or in the condition it's in right
now
right now
it's a 2021 you said you bought it in
the summer of 2021 you've been drag
racing or what what's the deal no no no
no no just no what is it worth today i
know i'm kidding what is it worth today
if you sold it today
probably
i locally i could probably get around
24-25 and dude you know what i'd say i'm
selling the car and driving a beater and
keeping the shoe collection you're 18
you live with your parents that's george
is right because here's the other
question i had
do you want to stay in the sneaker
business i mean are you do you know
enough about it
i i know i i know the market very well i
do this you know i
i've been doing the sneakers since 15
to now but i i've been mainly doing um
retail stuff so you don't want it
so you don't want to do it long term
no no if i can make a quick buck i will
but let me ask you this not something
how much of the 18 000 shoe collection
because you said part of it is you flip
them for some money the other part is
true collector so i'm going to engage
your collector's heart i'm just curious
how give me a round number because you
may not have thought through this how
many do you really want to keep if
you're going to sell some but others you
go i really want to hold on to these
just for
truly being a collector and letting them
go up in value from years and years from
now you got a number i have
i have i have around three pairs that i
i absolutely really don't want to let go
right how much are those
currently each of those are worth around
2
000 each so 6 grand
right all right george all right bryce
i'm gonna hand you to george george i
got an idea what if he sells every other
shoe
all right except those three which would
be about 12 grand he's going to net 12.
okay he sells the car
he thinks it's worth 25. let's say he's
right he owes 20. now he's got 17 and
he's debt free and he cuts the credit
card so he sells the car for 25 sells it
for 24 45. he knows off the 20. he nets
five on the car
plus the 12. that's seven plus he's got
17 cash and you can get a better car
than a beater okay but much better than
a beater and here's what i know about no
debt he can he could get this collection
back up and go into no time
i mean if a 15 year old can do this 18
year old bryce is even better at it now
george tell him why the credit cards is
stupid bryce you play with snakes you're
going to get bit and you're a sharp dude
you don't need to do this with debt you
told me right now that you don't even
like carrying debt so wide mess with it
when you have the cash then you're it's
pure profit at that point if you're
buying and selling shoes
right and same with your car you're
making payments on something that's
going down in value a car loan is one of
the stupidest decisions when it comes to
debt you could make and the truth is i
think you're an amazing amazing bright
young dude and you're going to crush it
for the rest of your life if you can
avoid debt
which i know you can bryce you can do it
with cash also three pairs of shoes for
six thousand dollars yeah whatever
that's what my last car cost me again
stop it george what are the shoes by the
way what are the shoes
the three pair
oh oh so so the the three pairs i have a
pair of um
off-white air force ones the university
gold pair that released in boston
and two pairs of travis scott jordan
ones and those are each worth two grand
each
about that and the size of yes what size
you got by the way i'm just curious ask
you for a friend
um this might be the first time someone
makes a deal live on the ramsay show
oh yeah no i'm not gonna pay you two
grand for a pair of tennis shoes man
oh we can wear something out of trouble
oh
i am interested in the off-white air
force ones we'll uh talk about it
hurts my brain does it hurt you what
happens if travis scott does something
stupid and all of a sudden the shoes are
worth zero because no one wants to be
associated with them well that's why i
didn't ask about the travis scott once
that's you make a very good point why
bryce by michael jordan's michael jordan
baby sure air force ones are air force
once that's true all right real quick
before we let you go young man you're
18. what do you have an idea what you
want to do you dreaming about something
no i i i'm not i'm not too sure right
now honestly are you in high school
still
no i i graduated uh in 21. are you
taking a gap year
i'm not sure about college right now
good man
all right hang on the line i'm going to
give you two things all right uh we're
going to give you the get clear career
assessment so 20 minute online
assessment all right and it's going to
help you get some real clarity on some
great ideas but more importantly a
purpose statement based on your talent
things you do best passion work you love
to do and mission results you want to
create and i'm also going to give you my
best-selling book from paycheck to
purpose think of the
get clear career assessment bryce as a
compass
and the book is kind of the guide up the
mountain hang on the line we're going to
give you both of those so kelly will
give him an assessment get clear career
assessment and the book from paycheck to
purpose boy he's one of those kids that
if he really listens to you on this
whole debt thing
he's going to be wildly successful
because he has the foundation he's got
the principles down of how to do
business yeah now we just have to do it
without debt so he's not calling back
going hey i'm 200 thousand dollars in
debt yeah because i thought i was going
to make a huge profit off this get rich
quick scheme yeah kelly ask him what the
ken coleman deal would be for the
off-white air force ones we'll see
uh we'll see during the commercial break
we'll see i think it's a little high
price for me george i don't think it's
in the envelope for this one would you
look cool in them i don't know i think i
would well i'll let kelly decide that oh
boy i know what the answer is now hey
but i also know we're coming right back
with more of your calls on the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined in studio by my colleague
and co-host george campbell
with a k
uh excited to have you with us triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're gonna get back to the phones
real quick george i wanted to call out
something i think is very relevant
to our audience
and that is that community college
enrollment is down but skilled trades
programs are booming
so this is a educational a get qualified
to make more money bigger shovel
and boy oh boy this the sands are
shifting
all right here's a quick snapshot where
we are since the pandemic began
so let's call it uh what march 2020
more than a million students have held
off from going to college opting to go
to work instead
uh our last caller 18 year old he
graduated 2021 kids making money selling
shoes
by the way i guess i should call back to
that kelly did pull up the air force
ones the off-white air force ones that i
was looking at
not for me
wow all right the deal is off bryce the
deal is off bryce well we still want you
to do everything else that george told
you to do
uh so bryce is an example though of here
he is he's out making money very
entrepreneurial
hasn't gone to school yet
uh two-year public schools have been
among the hardest hit that we're talking
about community colleges down about
three-quarters of a million students
george
that's 750 million george if you're
keeping support thank you for the math
on that skilled trades programs are the
exception across the country associates
degree programs it feels like hvac and
automotive repair are swelling this from
npr of this article i'm citing
now another area george that i think for
people that are handy and they're going
hey i want a side hustle
maybe a weekend gig
uh maybe if you've got a different kind
of a shift maybe you're working nights
and you want to make some money if you
know how to swing a hammer
oh yeah construction man huge there's a
shortage in qualified construction
workers
according to a september 2021 survey
of the associated general contractors of
america the survey found that 89 of
contractors are having a difficult time
finding workers who were trained for the
job that affects project timelines of
course 61 of contractors reported
project delays
uh because of workforce
uh shortages ken you're gonna love this
one the federal government only spends a
dollar on career training for every six
dollars it puts into college prep wow
so we're preparing kids for college for
the two to four years and nothing beyond
that nothing
uh and uh so let me just give this a
little bit of real
main street application
okay
let me tell you what a skilled
okay i don't mean like college we're
talking about traits
if you're good with a power saw a hammer
all that kind of stuff stuff that you
don't know you know what i'm talking
about you pay people and eat ice cream
while they do it
all right
you're looking at 250 bucks a day
right now in williamson county that air
this area around nashville 250 bucks a
day that's good money that's a minimum
so you know you're looking for that side
hustle george make some money to get out
of debt and here's the other thing
what we're seeing is is the reason that
people are pulling away from community
colleges they're becoming less and less
relevant
as opposed to going straight to a trade
school including technology schools
meaning not a traditional four-year
college
but uh ultimately some type of boot camp
like betheltech yeah which is a
nine-month program well the big thing is
people are rethinking the value of
college and this means securing a
high-paying job without taking on too
much debt because as we know the trades
are a really affordable way to get the
education you need to get the skills you
need to then get a really high paying
job at the end of that that's right so
big fan of the trades all right good
stuff let's go to bowling green kentucky
next where blake joins us blake how can
we help
hey guys good to talk to you good to
talk to you
so i already had a question about
uh just kind of looking for
a job and like
kind of what strategy to
use because i just recently finished up
college
um
and i got a mechanical engineering
degree
but um
you know i put in applications a bunch
of places
here there's a lot of
industry around here and a little bit
extended from the area
but um
just so i'm having a tough time with
that and i think
one
reason that it's hard is um i don't have
a lot of good like internship experience
or project experience
and
it seems like in interviews i don't have
a lot of times like good answers
for like you know
how i would handle like if they
give a hypothetical situation or or if
they say like tell me about
something
you know how you've handled this
situation in the past or something you
know what i mean what is your answer to
that
well
that's a i mean that was kind of a broad
question i mean it depends on what okay
but give me an example here's what i'm
wondering let me tell you why i'm
digging into this i'm wondering if
you're applying
for positions that you you really
shouldn't be applying for i wonder if
there's more of entry-level positions
that get you in where you don't have to
answer all those experience questions so
am i making sense
yeah i know what you mean so what's the
what's the answer you know your world
better than i do are there positions
that don't require that experience as
much so therefore you're not going to
bomb that question because that's really
what's going on
you're unable to answer it because you
don't have an answer is that true
uh yeah that's that's pretty much okay
then so so back to the question are
there what are entry-level positions for
a mechanical engineer do you know what
they are you don't have to tell me but
do you know what they are
i mean like what specific like roles i
would be yeah entry level meaning a guy
coming out of college with a mechanical
engineering degree doesn't need
experience because this is entry-level
do you know what those types of jobs are
i mean i don't know
particularly like and i know a lot of
the
some of the manufacturing plants hired
entry-level positions okay my point is
blake
at first i was wondering what your
strategies were but you're getting
interviews correct
i've gotten like a couple okay so i'm
going to give you some strategies
overall but i want to make sure you get
where i'm going
i you need to be looking for entry-level
positions in other words
no experience
i know but my point is keep looking
because they're out there
you know you're not the first student to
come out of mechanical with a mechanical
engineering degree or quite frankly any
engineering degree
and have to get in somewhere you're not
the first person to ever have to do this
where do those people go i mean this
might be a phone call back with your
professors or your career placement
people to go
where else do i need to be looking and
we need to be going after that now
that's the first part of my advice is
we got to go for jobs that don't require
experience because you don't have any
now the second piece is you mentioned
internship
this is about relationship and so are
getting more interviews so the next part
of my advice is all the same
how many people do you think give me a
ballpark you know
whether really closely or as an
acquaintance in bowling green kentucky
and surrounding areas how many people
just people period yeah how many people
do you know
uh
in your area
probably at least a couple hundred
couple hundred and how many people would
you say each of those couple hundred
people know
in the area
uh you know something similar or more
all right you're the smart engineering
guide you know what 200 times 200 is
what's the answer 400 000.
so you have access to a lot of people
and you got to start acting that way
this is about relationship relationship
relationship i'm going to give you my
best-selling book called proximity
principle
and this is a absolute step-by-step
guide to the people and places you need
to be putting yourself in right now and
you're going to get more interviews and
more importantly blake you're not just
going to get interviews you're going to
have a relationship that recommended you
for the interview and so they're already
going to have a great impression of you
before you ever walk in the door which
other in other words means you're going
to have a competitive advantage do you
understand what i'm saying
yeah george finally i just i just want
you to have some driving confidence man
i can hear it in your voice you sound
defeated and if you walked in with me
for an interview i'd be like i want a
guy who is passionate who cares so show
that in your next interview and go man i
don't have all the experience but i'm
willing to do whatever it takes to
figure out that's right i'm here for
this i want to be on your team i want
you guys to win i got the talent baby
the attitude i got the desire
i'm who you need i can do it but
leverage those relationships hang on the
line kelly's going to get you a copy of
the proximity principle read it do it
and watch the opportunities fly in for
you and you're going to crush them hey
big thanks to our team in the control
room who do this thing that we get to
call the ramsey show
big thanks to my colleague george
campbell and to you america this is the
ramsay show
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number i'm ken coleman
joined by my co-host colleague george
campbell with a k
eight eight two five five two two five
we're here to help you with your money
questions your work questions your
relationship questions uh just anything
around life what are we doing we're
gonna jump in and we're gonna look at
practical steps forward so that you can
get breakthrough and transformation
where you need it by the way all of
those areas george as you know
uh your work life your money life your
relationship life they're all connected
interwoven and if you're winning in one
and you're just falling apart in two or
any combination that's a flat tire you
can't drive like that yeah and you need
to be winning in all three
to really max out and live the life that
you're supposed to live and that you can
and should live so that's why we're here
you ready to get to the phones i'm
pumped all right dallas texas is where
we go ann is there and how can we help
hi it's so good to talk to you guys good
to talk to you what's up
so my question is i'm planning a
career transition to i know i'm gonna
have to get a pay cut
for a season and so i'm just wondering
how to best financially prepare
for that
transition what do you give us a little
bit more detail specifically what are
you transitioning to
and how big of a pay cut
i'm an occupational therapist i kind of
make pretty much the at the top of
my career field and so
um
the transition
um i make about a hundred thousand a
year okay
and
um
i'm transitioning to
go back to school in the near future
um so starting with kind of getting a
little bit more experienced so i know
i'm going to take a pick up to about
i'm anticipating 60
000
a year
okay so 60 to 70 you're going to be
working while you go to school
you'll see this
initial transition to get like a certain
amount of experience because i'm
planning to get my phd
um so i need research experience and so
that job will give me the research
experience which is about a year
and then
that's to get me back to going to a phd
program which i don't have to pay for
but i know it's like a stipend which
brings me down to like 30 a year
depending on the program
and then
i know i'm going to be working because
my job i will be able to work
while i go to school what are you going
into phd and what to do what
um
it's
so that's kind of where i'm still unsure
um as far as like the program but
definitely going into like a
neuroscience phd okay all right well we
you didn't call for that specific issue
so i don't want to take you too far down
that path so if i heard this right
yeah you need to you need to because i
want to make sure even though that phd
is being paid for i want to make sure
that that's the right path because we're
talking about some serious financial
sacrifice if i heard this right george
yeah she's making a hundred now
she's going to take a job that'll give
her the research experience that's going
to put her between 60 and 70.
uh and then if you get in and you still
move forward on the phd program then
you're going to go all the way down to
just living off that stipend uh real
quick before i hand you off to george on
this are you in one income you in a
relationship double income what's going
on
uh one income single i'm completely debt
free
i have a fully funded emergency fund and
then i have like
like another twenty thousand just saved
up as a regular and you're you're
incredible most people in your shoes
they go yeah i got 80 000 student loans
for my occupational therapy degree and
now i don't know what to do but you're
in a great financial position
and so what is the how urgent is this uh
program coming up
are you entering this this fall
no so
i still have to apply for it
um and then it's like
in the next year
okay
now in your financial position
could you live off of 60 000
uh yeah currently i'm like living off of
40. hey
that's i mean if you can learn to live
on this then when you go down to 60
you're you're not going to feel it that
much where's all the extra money going
right now just in the savings you said
you had 20 set aside
yeah it's going into my savings i paid
off every i paid off my student loans
last year
um so i went to that
and then
so this is some newer income you now
have that's not going towards debt
right and so i kind of just want to know
like how to allocate it
because i know we want to save or we
want to know where everything goes and
so that's kind of weird yeah are you
doing a monthly budget currently
um i'm not the dashed at it but yes
can i help you out with that
i'll gift you one year of ramsay plus
which will include every dollar plus our
premium budgeting tool and that will
connect to your bank account it'll make
it super easy to track because
making a budget's one thing tracking it
is really where you see the progress so
if you do that if i give you that would
you do it
yeah awesome well hang on the line kelly
will get that for you and we'll also
give you uh financial peace universities
included inside of ramsey plus so watch
those videos because you're on the path
you're doing this stuff but i want you
to stay on the path as your income goes
down because the key here is keeping
margin in your life regardless of your
income and if you still have money left
over making 60 making 30 or you
supplement it with some of that savings
to get you through that program you're
gonna be doing real good on the other
side of this with no debt and a huge
pile of money yeah i mean she is off to
a fantastic start i was really cringing
waiting for her to share with us than
the numbers yeah but she's she's got a
great emergency fund
uh just really rolling along to this to
this end ken i want to remind people the
options that you have when you do what
ended when you can go to school do a
debt free or pay off the student loans
really fast if you've already got them
no the options it gives you to even
enter a program like this and not be as
worried if you had 100 grand in debt
you can't go down to 30. you can't
breathe i will tell you i'm glad you
brought that up because her piece ann's
got true financial peace and and i by
the way i ann i do hope you call my show
call the king coleman show because i'd
like to spend a little bit of time
diving deep
on
maybe the direction she could go because
you heard her go i'm not 100 sure so in
this case before even though she's got
the phd paid for it which i thought that
was wonderful yeah
it's still time george
the money's not the factor but it's
still the time
and i'd hate to see somebody pursue a
phd
not being sure what's on the other side
of that yeah let's spend the extra time
necessary on the front end
as opposed to spending a two three year
phd program well she sounds real driven
and the fact that she said well mario at
the top of this and i i don't think it's
just about money for her i think she
does want to just grow in her career
very much as well and if there's money
on the other side of that that's great
impact and income yeah and i think she
that's it i think she knows the
direction she needs to spend a little
extra time getting clear before we make
a time commitment you know the two most
important things time and money man and
and it's not always just a money play
time because by the way that's money she
doesn't need a phd and she can get right
into the field start making more money
that's just advancing two to three years
worth of income
which is what we talk about here on the
ramsay show talking about your income is
your greatest wealth building tool so
good stuff thank you so much for the
call uh well sharp sharp sharp young
lady that's so exciting don't tell me
these young people don't have a bright
future that's just garbage all right
don't move more of your calls coming up
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
welcome back america you have joined the
conversation here on the ramsey show i'm
ken coleman joined by my co-host and
colleague george campbell the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five
two two five let's go to tampa florida
maria is on the line there maria how can
we help
hello hi maria how are you
hi guys thank you so much for your time
um so i have small children so i'll just
get right to it okay um i am wondering
how my husband can transition working as
a 1099 contractor for a locally owned
tow truck company to doing it for
ourselves and i can provide any context
you'd like okay so uh this might shock
you i don't know much about the tow
company business so uh okay there's a
big need not enough drivers and a lot of
people who need help um essentially the
owner is a buddy of ours who is
fairly removed from the operation due to
personal health reasons
and so my husband is actually
dispatching his own tow truck calls as
the only tow truck driver right now so
if your husband he's doing all the work
right no i get it so the need is great
that's a good sign for a new business
the question is what kind of equipment
is he going to need besides a tow truck
and how does one go about getting a tow
truck if you don't have the cash to pay
for it because you know we're not going
to recommend that he go into debt so how
would he do that
that's where we're asking so we are
still on baby step two for our household
we have about eight thousand dollars
left in debt um and that's the thing so
the truck is expensive used or new very
expensive but that is
the expensive part of getting started we
don't really need anything else to just
get going how much is a tow truck used
a lot like
50 000
and we don't want to do that we can't do
that we don't want to do that my mom
said she'd buy it we don't want her to
do that
but here's the deal when he's taking
calls all week long we split him 50 50
with the owner when he is taking so he
earns a total of 4 000 a week on average
for the company
but then we have to split that and then
we pay the fuel
so we pay about about 50 about 20 of
that 20 percent of fuel and then 30
percent come from with us
before taxes
is he making close to six figures then
before we have to split yeah and then so
for our home our take-home pay no but
for what the company is earning with
just his driving and dispatching yes and
that's where we're like okay
like let's do this on our own so we
could not have to cut this bike
and the owner had a whole bunch of that
he did it the wrong way we're so
grateful for him but he did it like
every wrong way possible and so every
his entire 50 is just like that how how
willing will the owner be to let him
take over if he's kind of unable to run
it
that is a wonderful question i'm just
wondering how hard is it to start a tow
truck business from scratch and build
the
of the business yeah it's a good
question george but marie i don't like
it i don't think that's what you were
saying george but i don't want them
taking over a businesses saddled with
debt
my question you would hand it over we
would do it well i would not take the
debt with that no you do not do that
it's not worth it oh is that what you
mean don't take the debt yeah don't take
the debt let me ask you this
are you suggesting if i if i came up
with 50 grand right now magically
for the used uh tow truck is that all he
needs is one truck to be able to do the
numbers you're telling me or is it much
more than that
more trust no literally literally needs
the truck to get the truck registered
and licensed in the state
and then we already have without being
unethical and shady to the owner because
it's information that can be publicly
sourced we already have the contact
information for the contracts required
to take calls in our area to produce at
the same volume that he is the only
difference would be
who the contractors that were
we are being reached by like hey our
client needs the trouble on the side of
the road um who's our pain
let me ask a silly question
can you rent the truck could you rent a
truck
i have considered asking the owner if we
could rent his truck but he doesn't seem
much willing to move much past the 50
as when we started we were at 30 and now
he's giving him 50 and he kind of seems
to be really stuck there i think he has
bills and he's not earning any money
anywhere else
and we've got dreams we've got goals i
would love to be the one that gets to
decide where that four grand every week
goes no i told you i'll be going to debt
but my point is if even if it's not the
owner
who else would rent you a tow truck
because now george george correct me but
this is a cash flow game and so i know
they got debt i'd like to see the 8 000
gone you're saying if you can rent it
for a thousand you can make four
if you can rent it now we're not in debt
it's a cash flow of getting the business
going
i would look into renting the truck
in order to save up the 50k to buy one
used eventually eventually you build the
business
i'm sorry for doing this while we have
our own debt like
if it was going to cost seven thousand
dollars to register you guys can pay off
your debt real fast you have eight
thousand dollars in debt that needs to
be gone within a few months i do that
first
and you don't have an emergency fund
right
correct how much money do you guys have
one really fast i have three uh i have
three thousand dollars because we just
had a baby
and we haven't i haven't moved it out
yet right now um in our savings yes okay
so what we need to do is we need to get
rid of this 8000 then we need to save up
three to six months of expenses
and then we can focus on first of all we
need to be investing too there's other
parts of life
so and how old are you two
um in our late 20s okay have you started
investing at all
no we haven't we've had debt since our
honeymoon that's where it started well
this is the year if you can get rid of
this debt get the emergency fund in
place you can be investing before the
year is over 15 of your income then
beyond that i want you to start to build
this business so we need to put pause on
this business right now that's correct
while we clean up the mess because then
you're gonna have some financial peace
some stability a foundation
then we can focus on getting this
business off the ground and we're gonna
do it with cash don't get starry-eyed
and take out a loan for fifty thousand
because you can make four a week yeah
and and george i'm so glad that you
walked her through that because folks
are other people in the same situation
and maria need to understand this that
toe business is still going to be there
it's still still need a toe
imagine that the opportunity for you and
your husband is going to be there and
the good news is you'll have no personal
debt you have a fully funded emergency
fund you'll be in baby step four where
you're putting 15
towards your retirement you'll be saving
up for those babies educational
and the business will still be there
i get it i i want to say that i
completely understand there's an angst
there
for for her and her husband because
they're looking at the numbers on paper
they're going we're getting ripped off
man they're going oh the opportunity is
huge but it's like oh well you're not
taking into account
if one thing
or one and a half things
or two or three things go wrong
and you're in debt
this big dream falls apart and the very
dream becomes a nightmare
that's a good word you know my barber
did this he was working for a place and
they get you know 50
of the cut so he went hey i can make 100
if it's in my own chair but that means
starting my own business and so he
started making that move
and uh ended up switching over yeah it
can be done all right so let me ask
everybody a question when you think of a
millionaire what kind of job do you
picture millionaires having is it some
kind of high-powered executive like a vp
or ceo
well here's the reality only 15 of
millionaires actually have jobs like
that the reality is that top five
careers for millionaires in america are
engineer accountant teacher manager
and attorney that's just one of the
surprising things our team found out
when we conducted the largest study of
millionaires that has ever been done our
study also made it clear that to become
a millionaire you've got to invest
wisely george was just talking about
this and a big part of that is getting
good investing advice
you need to work with an investing pro
who can walk with you
and teach you about the options that are
right for you so you actually understand
what you're investing in and why you're
investing in it our team recommends
trustworthy
vetted investing pros from all
over the country we call those folks
smart investor pros if you would like to
get in touch with a smart investor pro
in your area and you can they're
everywhere go to ramseysolutions.com
smart vester and start building wealth
today that's ramsay solutions
dot com slash
smart vester all right
uh george we still got calls to take man
the phones are lighting up triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
gonna get to all of them coming up next
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show
i like that vibe right there that music
[Music]
feels very get smart uh the old school
nick at night for those of you that are
old enough ken you're showing your age
again i know i'm dating myself i feel
like a little 1965 spy novel you also
mentioned thelma and louise to a couple
out during the break i had to google it
you don't know thelma louise i've heard
about it but it's one of the great road
trip movies of all time yeah from the
80s all right he's george campbell i'm
ken coleman whoa kelly's offended shots
fired by young george i don't watch
movies that aren't in 16 by nine and in
color ken okay i'm sorry
i have standards
what year what year were you born 89
1989
we'll just leave it at that triple eight
eight two five five two two five you're
a resident millennial george thank you
some people are offended by the fact
that i was born when i was born i can't
help it no it's not your it's not your
call thank you it was a great time at
least you were born in the 80s i feel
good that i escaped the 90s one of the
great decades of all time triple eight
eight two five five two two five
jacqueline joins us in fort worth
texas
jacqueline how can we help
hello
hi
hi
how are you
i was doing great i hated you i'm glad
you all talked because i didn't want to
come after that lady dude but there's
hope for her but i'm in a good spot with
my house okay good good
how can we help just want to make sure
i want to do a do-over and i'm kind of
excited about it um
i get i want to make sure it's not a
money motivator
i'm thinking about selling my house i
went to open house in the neighborhood
and the house was selling like for 80
000 more
than i paid for my house and it's the
same exact house built the same year
yeah
so
when i fail at night i'm gonna be okay
but uh this one make sure i'm making the
so why are you looking to sell me
well
it's not
i'm not in love with it but it's a nice
house how long have you been in the
house
uh i'm gonna wait until november it'll
be two years okay i want to avoid the
capital gains okay good and why are you
selling are you trying to pay off debt
no i'm in a good start with that i am
for the past five years and i only get i
have is a
six thousand dollar consolidation that i
did
i paid out two cars i'm gonna pay off a
lot of stuff good so you have six
thousand left so you don't need to sell
the house
huh you don't need to sell the house in
order to pay off the debt you can just
do that just through your cash no i
don't need to sell the house to pay out
the debt but me selling
i was going to move and go back home
fort worth is not my home
and you know i can help my sister
without moving with my sister but i want
to do a do-over i want to get
another house it's not my ultimate how
much would you make on the house after
you pay off the loan
i'm not sure but it's i don't even think
they're gonna get that
if they sell in the house for 80 more
than that pay for it i'm assuming
somewhere between 30 and 50 000. is what
you would net even after closing costs
i'm thinking that just
this is let's call it 30.
so now you you skip town and you got 30
000 to your name you've got no debt do
you have a fully funded emergency fund
okay dad
i'm working on
well that would become your emergency
fund right
because by november more than cover my
emergency fund i'll be debt free in the
full upon the emergency fund okay good
because by november this debt should be
gone the six thousand and then oh yeah
this is still going to be gone
by june july or before okay and i would
try to cash flow that emergency fund so
that when you sell the house at 30 000
you can use towards your next goal your
next down payment wherever you're moving
to live
that's what i was saying to do i wanted
to do a do-over to do it the
that's the plan i'll recommend it i mean
you just told me you don't you don't
like the house and you want to move you
don't want to even live there anymore i
don't hate the house but
i'm in texas and my home is georgia
jaclyn you just said i don't want to
live in fort worth it's not my home i
don't like the house
just move it's that simple wait till
november
it's
don't over complicate it yeah there it
is i think tonight go ahead and uh you
know maybe play a little james brown
georgia in the background
i didn't know where you're going with
that okay she wants to go back home yeah
she wants to be near her sister uh
presumably some other family and in the
meantime before you list it yeah let's
pay off the debt let's get the emergency
fund in place yeah in this case she
don't want to be there there's no
long-term reason for the house so in
this case she just wanted some
confirmation yeah there you go well i
appreciate the call jacqueline i love it
all right george today's uh question of
the day from blinds.com uh find out uh
for yourself folks why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
make sure that you use the promo code
ramsay so that you get the best deal
today's question comes from jennifer in
wisconsin she says currently my husband
and i are on baby step 2. i have a
full-time job in accounting and i also
work part-time in the evenings and on
weekends my part-time schedule does not
conflict with my full-time job at all my
boss heard that i was working two jobs
and was concerned about it honestly i
believe it's coming from a good place he
gave me a pretty decent raise so that i
don't have to work two jobs that was
very gracious of him however i want to
continue working both jobs until we're
in baby step three i did scale back on
hours at the second job but i'm
concerned that he may find out that i'm
continuing to work the second job is it
wrong to have two jobs if they don't
conflict with each other no
it's not wrong
and and you should not be worried
about him finding out if you're still
working the second job unless we're
missing something in the question
um you know he may mean well
but what fear is driving this leader's
decision to kind of go hey
i'm concerned about you working two jobs
here's where the question comes in for
jennifer
was your performance in any way slipping
was it being affected by the second job
if the answer george is unequivocally no
then you know i mean at the end of the
day it's not his call yeah and if she
hasn't had the conversation with him i
mean she can be as honest as she wants
she doesn't have to tell him anything
but if you want to have the conversation
and say hey listen i appreciate the
raise i love working here i have no
plans of going anywhere i'm taking these
second jobs because i want to pay off
this debt faster i want to get my place
i want financial peace tell them how
long i'm i'm anticipating that we're
going to be at baby step 3 be through it
at this point at which point i am not
going to work two jobs maybe you get him
on the ramsey plan maybe that would be
cool but it's truly none of his business
and it's not in direct competition you
didn't sign some kind of non-compete
that's right here in the accounting
world i don't know what you're even
doing there's no conflict of interest at
all
so his concern is very sweet but we tell
him hey thanks for your concern but you
don't pay my debt payments therefore you
don't get a vote oh it's a very nice way
of saying pound sand
thank you ken or go fly a kite go fly a
kite is another face either one would be
uh unkind yeah and old-timey by the way
it's so funny phrases like that go fly a
kite you know
my dad would say that when i was growing
up like irritating somebody like ah they
tell those people to go fly a kite but
you never actually told them to go fly a
kite because if you did it would kind of
be
the reverse of what you were trying to
do which is a good bus well in hindsight
those were very kind statements these
days i don't get that in traffic ken no
one's telling me to go fly kite or pound
sand no they do way worse they say way
worse things that's right but now here's
the deal this is actually an important
issue
people feel pressure
from their leaders sometimes
that may not actually be there
or if it's there
it's
you don't have to feel that pressure
because we have a lot of people that are
listening and watching this show that
are getting after it with the second job
george the third job they're gazelle
intense so when we talk about gazelle
intensity here on this program many
times that means multiple jobs so it is
a very key point that i want to make
here that
we're all about you working the two and
three jobs right
but you better do a good job at all
three of them and certainly if we if we
say that
the second job or the third job are just
part-time gigs that
primary job is vitally important
so that means
you got to bring it
you can't be sloughing off because
you're tired because it is not a good
excuse
to your leader at your primary job well
i'm working two or three other jobs to
pay off debt i'm sorry i just fell
asleep while i was driving the forklift
oh yikes
you know what i'm saying yeah so
understand that they have no ability to
tell you yay or nay and they're not
gonna say much at all if you're crushing
it that's my point they may have a
concern but if you give them no reason
for concern it's okay go keep work i
wouldn't have cut back on the hours is
my point jennifer keep at it take the
raise and keep the hours going that
means we're getting out of debt even
faster we're getting baby step three
faster which means we're quitting that
job the extra job so keep your chin up
jennifer keep on going hey we're gonna
keep on going george you good i'm good
all right we're gonna keep on going
don't move more of the ramsey show
coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague co-host
george campbell
our scripture of the day comes from
james 4 verse 10. humble yourselves
before the lord and he will lift you up
our quote from bill bradley uh u.s
senator bill bradley who was also george
you have any idea what he was famous for
before becoming a u.s senator not a clue
ken nba basketball player that's in my
head i thought bill bradley is a
basketball thing i bet you did uh he is
our quote of the day becoming number one
is easier
than remaining number one
that's good
a lot easier to climb
than it is to stay on top to maintain
very interesting good stuff all right
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five
two two five let's go to daniel now who
joins us in phoenix arizona daniel how
can we help
hi guys uh
my name is daniel
and uh i'm working as an electrical
apprentice
in a company
and i had a question today about you
know where to go in my career right now
so i've been working at this company for
almost about two years
and right now we're doing this project
where they just had me driving a water
truck
for like 10 hours a day
and i was wondering you know should i
look somewhere else you know because i'm
also going to a trade school right now
currently and i'm learning a lot of
stuff but they just had me driving a
water truck and i don't feel like i'm
learning anything you know it's
electrical so i should really be
you know out in the field and i i talked
to my boss about it a couple of times
and he just would tell me you know oh
well you know that's where we need you
right now
and you know and it's been going on for
about like i don't know close to like
five six months
and i'm kind of wondering you know like
what's going on here should i just apply
somewhere else because i know uh
especially here in the phoenix area
there's tons of electrical jobs
everywhere yeah well
two-part question
had you done electrical work for them
before
in your two years have you done
electrical work for them
yeah i've done i've ran pipe for them
all kinds of stuff and then what are you
in a print oh excuse me what are you in
trade school learning
to do electric electrical so when will
you be done
uh i'll be finished with school in about
maybe like
two more years
so two more years of trade school and
how much further up the ladder will that
qualify you for in other words is there
a pay grade that those two years of
trade school is gonna make you qualified
for versus just staying with this
current company or going to another
company what's the difference
well if i go to another company i feel
like they'd have me doing more trade
stuff instead of just you know well i
appreciate that but my question is if
you do go to another company and let's
say you're not driving trucks they've
got you doing electrical work you know
all day every day
how much more qualified does the trade
school make you or do you even need the
trade school if you're working as an
electrician for somebody else
yeah that's a good question everyone you
know always tells me like oh you know
you don't need to go to school but
the school actually really qualifies you
to become an actual what they call a
journeyman electrician that's my
question so that how much more money
could you make as a journeyman versus
what you're doing now just as
a non-journeyman electrician
so right now i'm probably like close to
like 20 an hour but as a actual
journeyman i'll i should be making at
least like 30 32. okay great
all right so obviously you need to
continue trade school i think that's the
right move there's no question about it
that gets you further up the ladder um i
think you can start looking for jobs in
other places
you know i mean your low man on the
totem pole is what it sounds like to me
meaning maybe the least amount of
experience is that true or is that false
uh yeah but there's guys that are coming
in like less experienced than me too as
well so yeah i guess i'm climbing it up
right but i mean are those guys that are
coming in with less experience are they
doing electrical work while you're
driving the water truck
yeah like you know there'll be new
buyers and then you know it's kind of
like oh well we need you here but
there's i see other guys brand new in
the trade doing electrical too well why
do you think they got you driving the
water truck
uh well it kind of started where like
they were like oh like you have a
driving driver's license i was like yeah
and then they're like well let's see if
we can get you approved
and then i was like that's fine and then
you know like i got approved and i
thought it was only going to be for like
maybe a month or two but coming off five
months now and now they're like oh well
we still need you here so they have a
bigger need because some of these other
guys probably don't have valid driver's
licenses sounds like to me
yeah that's kind of what it is all right
all right now listen listen get your
chin up because this is a now we got a
little bit more information
i understand you want to be doing
electrical work and you need to be
looking for other electrician jobs in
phoenix it's a hot market yes but don't
get discouraged the reason they've got
you driving the truck is not because
they devalue you because i think i hear
a little bit of that on you and i
understand that the reason they have you
driving the truck is because you're
probably one of the few guys with a
legitimate driver's license or
non-suspended driver's license and all
that other stuff so don't get down
just get determined you hear me and
let's start looking today
so you're saying uh find a different job
yes sir
no i'm saying go look for another job
where you can do electrical work
yes sir where they don't need a driver
you see what i'm saying
yeah perfect but i just don't want you
yeah i just don't want you to be
discouraged
george he's feeling stuck yeah and we
can get unstuck with all the positions
available and we know the trades are hot
so the finished transport tree yeah so
daniel finished finished trade school
and i'm seeing average salary for a
journeyman electrician in the phoenix
area 50 60 upwards of 80. so he can make
good money if he finishes
good money yeah very good money i love
it all right let's get to kimberly in
colorado springs colorado kimberly how
can we help
hi ken hi george um
i'm actually surprised i got through but
um hi i'm on baby step two well my
family and i are baby stuff too
my husband is currently
he's been with his job for like 13 years
and he's not exactly happy with it
anymore but he's looking at other jobs
but he's also scared to venture out into
finding another job because we don't
have that much in savings right now
um so i'm just trying to figure out
should we be pouring our money into
savings instead of debt or vice versa
what's he doing now
um he works in i.t for a school
okay what's he wanting to do
um he still wants to work in i.t um he
just
i mean i guess he feels comfortable on a
school environment but um
why can't he just apply for jobs and
then when he gets the job he takes the
job
there doesn't have to be this weird gap
where he just quits for no reason and
then hopes he finds a job in i.t
well
yeah i mean i guess he could do that um
i the problem is is like okay so he's on
the autism spectrum so it's hard for him
to find a job to where
um they can meet all of his needs i
guess where he's
comfortable in the work that they give
him
and also he's kind of he gets
overwhelmed very easily and so not a lot
of people are willing to hire him okay
so kimberly even more what george said
we don't leave this current job that is
giving him those benefits or the benefit
of the doubt if he will right
we don't leave this until we have
something already signed and ready to go
there's no interruption in income the
last thing you want to do in his very
unique situation
is rely on savings because even if you
saved up four or five six months it is
possible
that you could burn through that
yeah
don't
leave until he has another job to leave
too
so my fear is if he does leave a job and
he takes another job that makes about
the same amount
what if he doesn't do well in that job
and there's not really much
else he can do you know so
are you working as well outside the home
i'm not um i'm a stay-at-home mom i have
a one well she's about to turn one no so
well kimberly i know this is this is a
hard thing that you're grappling with
being a stay-at-home mom with the
husband who's got a unique work
situation
uh but the best thing he can do is apply
for other jobs and have the confidence
that he's gonna be able to do it and if
he makes it through the process and they
they see the value in him working there
and he has the confidence he's going to
be all right yeah and and i up to this
point he's been successful i hear a lot
of years yeah i hear a lot of fear in
your voice but for 13 years he's held
down a job at this place
and i if that's where he needs to be
because it's the safest environment but
do the homework why has he succeeded for
13 years well it has to be true for him
to succeed somewhere else go look for
that find that doesn't need to be so
much fear around the unknown when you
guys know what will work george campbell
thanks for hanging out with me great
stuff i want to thank our team in the
control room thank you all so very much
well thank you america this is your show
this is the ramsey show
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you